Es posible que estés pensando que de un tiempo
a esta parte en VisualPolitik estamos hablando
una barbaridad de Argentina.
Y no te falta
razón hemos hecho un montón de vídeos sobre
el país del tango.
Pero, ¿qué queréis que os diga? Argentina
es un país super interesante. Al fin y al
cabo, ¿Sabéis decirme algún otro país
que durante las últimas 6 décadas, de media
haya tenido que negociar un rescate con el
FMI cada 4 años y medio?
Argentina se ha convertido casi en un sinónimo
de crisis…
Qué diantres,Argentina es el país de las
crisis.
Argentina sufre el segundo mayor colapso de
cualquier mercado de valores desde 1950, y
la nación está nuevamente al borde de una
crisis financiera.
Amigos, os doy mi palabra, durante toda mi
vida no recuerdo una sóla época dónde la
actualidad argentina no estuviera marcada
por los problemas económico.
(La hiperinflación de finales de los 80,
el default y el corralito de principios de
siglo o el colapso económico que el país
está viviendo desde el año 2015 y que le
ha obligado a negociar otra vez con el FMI.
En esta ocasión un rescate de, ni más ni
menos, que 56 mil millones de dólares.
Sí, habéis escuchado bien, 56.000 millones
de dólares.
Evidentemente tener taantos problemas económicos
tiene consecuencias. Durante los últimos
100 años, Argentina ha pasado de ser uno
de los 10 países más ricos del planeta en
términos per cápita a situarse en la posición
64. Esto es, al nivel de Bielorrusia, Turkmenistán
o Irán.)
[Y lo peor de todo es que no deja de caer
en este ranking.]
Pero amigos durante los últimos años un
sueño ha recorrido Argentina y con él la
esperanza de que los problemas puedan quedar
de una vez por todas atrás.
En el siglo XIX la lana fue el motor de Argentina,
a comienzos del pasado siglo la carne, la
famosa carne argentina, a mediados del siglo
XX el trigo y ahora muchos sueñan con que
el gas y el petróleo puedan cambiar la suerte
del país.
Y esta esperanza tiene nombre propio: Vaca
Muerta.
Atentos.
(VACA MUERTA, EL ÚLTIMO TESORO)
Vale, que le vamos a hacer, no tiene el nombre
más bonito ni el más romántico, pero tras
esta denominación se encuentra uno de los
grandes tesoros de la Argentina.
Pero…un momento ¿Qué diantres es Vaca
Muerta?
[Esa es la pregunta que creo tenemos que hacernos
antes de nada.]
Vaca Muerta, amigos, es una formación geológica
que tiene la capacidad de convertir a este
país en toda una potencia exportadora de
gas.
Situada en el borde occidental de la Patagonia
argentina, cerca de los Andes y en mitad de
una estepa árida y solitaria, Vaca Muerta
es la auténtica protagonista de noticias
como esta:
(Vaca Muerta. La producción de gas de junio
fue la más alta en 11 años. El mes pasado
se produjo un total de 140 millones de metros
cúbicos por día, lo que significó un crecimiento
interanual del 5,8%. Es la mayor producción
de gas en once años. La Nación)
Ojo, no estamos ante un descubrimiento que
podamos decir que es estrictamente nuevo.
El yacimiento de Vaca Muerta fue hallado por
el geólogo estadounidense Charles Weaver
ni más ni menos que en el año 1931. Sin
embargo, hasta hace relativamente poco no
ha sido posible hacer nada con él.
Vaca Muerta, amigos, es un yacimiento de hidrocarburos no convencionales, es decir, de “Shale oil”
cuando se extrae petróleo y “Shale gas”
cuando se extrae gas.
(Pues bien, el caso es que en este lugar los
hidrocarburos se encuentran repartidos a lo
largo y ancho de una superficie de 30.000km2….
una superfice equivalente a 2 veces Kuwait.
Sólo hay un problema, a diferencia de lo
que ocurre en Oriente Medio aquí no basta
con pinchar el suelo para que brote el petróleo
o el gas, porque aquí, en Vaca Muerta todos
estos recursos, los hidrocarburos están a
unos 3.000 metros de profundidad.)
[Vaya puñeta]
Y… esperad porque ahí no terminan los problemas.
Hay otro inconveniente aún peor.
(En este caso el petróleo y el gas están
confinados dentro de rocas así que para poder
explotarlos hay que construir un pozo y a
través de él inyectar una sustancia a presión
que permita fracturar esas rocas para que
el petróleo y el gas pueden emerger por el
mismo pozo.
Es una cuestión de presión, cuando se libera
el petroleo y el gas de la roca estos compuestos
emergén con una enorme fuerza. Como cuando
abrimos una botella agitada de Coca Cola o
gaseosa)
[Exactamente, estamos hablando del polémico
fracking o fractura hidráulica.]
Este es el motivo por el que Vaca Muerta no
se ha podido explotar hasta hace relativamente
poco.
Ahora bien, llegados a este punto, hay un
pregunta que estoy convencido a muchos os
ronda por la cabeza.
¿De cuánto petróleo y de cuanto gas estamos
exactamente hablado? Porque esa es la cuestión
clave.
¿Realmente puede el yacimiento de Vaca Muerta
suponer un antes y un después para la Argentina?
Atentos.
(OXÍGENO FRENTE A LA CRISIS)
Para continuar esta historia tenemos que remontarnos
hasta el 2011. Ese año, Repsol, una petrolera
española, anunció el “mayor descubrimiento
de su historia”:
(Repsol YPF anuncia el mayor descubrimiento
de petróleo de su historia. Repsol YPF calcula
que existen unos recursos de petróleo y gas
recuperables equivalentes a 927 millones de
barriles de petróleo. El País (7/11/2011))
Pero eso amigos no era más que el comienzo.
(Hoy se considera que como mínimo Vaca Muerta
es el segundo mayor yacimiento de todo el
mundo de gas no convencional y el cuarto mayor
de shale oil.
De hecho, según las estimaciones de la Agencia
de la Energía de los Estados Unidos, las
reservas, ojo, explotables a día de hoy de
este yacimiento ascienden a 16.000 millones
de barriles de petróleo y 308 trillones de
pies cúbicos de gas natural)
Pero… Ahora bien, ¿Cuánto suponen realmente
estas cantidades?
Pues amigos, para que os hagáis una idea…
16.000 millones de barriles de petróleo equivalen
a dos veces las reservas de petróleo convencional
de países como Noruega o Angola. Son casi
60 años del consumo de petróleo que tiene
Argentina.
(Y en cuanto al gas natural… el consumo
de Argentina viene a ser aproximadamente de
1 trillón de pies cúbicos… Es decir, para
que nos entendamos. Tan solo las reservas
explotables de Vaca Muerta, 308 trillones
de pies cúbicos de gas natural, equivalen
a casi 300 años del consumo de gas de la
Argentina.)
[Vamos que en vez de Vaca Muerta tendría
que llamarse Vaca Gorda. Hablamos de una vaca
cargada hasta reventar...y no precisamente
de leche, sino de petróleo y gas]
(Todo esto significa que en poco tiempo la
Argentina podría por un lado tener una importante
ventaja competitiva: disponer de energía
barata. Y no hay nada que le venga mejor a
la industria que poder disponer de energía
barata.
Por otro lado, el país también podrá hincharse
a exportar gas natural, no solo a sus vecinos
latinoamericanos, sino fundamentalmente al
resto del mundo, especialmente a Asia.)
Y esto es interesante, porque seguro que la
mayoría de vosotros estáis preocupados por
la sostenibilidad y el medio ambiente, ¿Verdad?
¿A quién no le gustaría que en poco tiempos
las energías renovables y las fuentes de
energía menos contaminantes tuvieran un papel
protagonista?
Sin embargo hasta llegar a ese punto hay un
paso mucho más urgente que dar: sustituir
el carbón en los procesos de producción,
especialmente en los países emergentes, como
China que aún genera el 70% de su electricidad
quemando carbón.
Con su enorme población y su gran dependencia
del carbón, China es, con mucho, el mayor
contaminador del mundo. Es responsable de
más emisiones que los Estados Unidos y la
UE combinados.
Y amigos, en esta misión, tanto por coste
como por tecnología, el gas natural función
a las mil maravillas y desde luego es mucho
más limpio que el petróleo y muchísimo
más limpio que el carbón. Así que incluso
si hablamos en términos de sostenibilidad
Vaca Muerta es una gran noticia.
Pero un momento, llegados a este punto puede
que alguno de vosotros esté pensando que
bueno… Sí, tal vez, ya si eso, igual dentro
de muchooos años todo esto le sirve de algo
a La Argentina.
Pues amigos, no podríais estar más equivocados.
Vaca Muerta ya está teniendo consecuencias
muy positivas para la economía argentina.
Veréis, la falta de inversión y el declive
de los viejos yacimientos provocó que desde
el año 2008 la Argentina haya tenido que
importar una enorme cantidad de gas natural
y petróleo, lo que por supuesto supuso un
déficit mucho más alto en la balanza comercial
y una enorme salida de dólares del país.
Sin embargo ahora eso está empezando a cambiar.
("La producción de crudo acumula 16 meses
de crecimiento interanual ininterrumpido.
El no convencional, que tuvo un aumento del
47%, ya representa un 18% de la producción
total. Hace 14 meses que la Argentina no debe
recurrir a las importaciones de petróleo"
Gustavo Lopetegui, Secretario de Energía.)
Y con el gas natural tres cuartas partes de
lo mismo. Desde 2017 las importaciones netas
se han reducido más de un 50%.
("Nuestro gran desafío es continuar aumentando
la producción para abastecer el mercado interno
y poder convertirnos en exportadores de gas
durante todos los meses del año. Esto nos
permitirá converger a precios menores para
el mercado interno, tanto para hogares como
para el sector industrial". Gustavo Lopetegui,
Secretario de Energía.)
Evidentemente sin este cambio la crisis que
actualmente atraviesa argentina hubiera sido
aún peor, mucho peor.
[O lo que es lo mismo, vamos, que si Mauricio
Macri no hubiera tenido Vaca Muerta
ya no es que hubiera sacado unos malos resultados es que no le habrían votado ni en su casa.]
Y desde luego sin este lugar la situación
de Argentina sería aún mucho peor.]
El caso, amigos, es que si se logra poner
a trabajar este yacimiento a pleno rendimiento
tan solo el impacto en la balanza exterior
del país podría ser enorme.
Según Carlos Ormachea, presidente de Tecpretol,
una de las empresas que está trabajando en
este sitio, estaríamos hablando de un impacto
positivo de 30.000 millones de dólares anuales.
20.000 millones en exportaciones y otros 10.000
millones de dólares que no saldrían del
país para comprar hidrocarburos.
Y desde luego tooodos esos dólares le vendrían
muy bien al país para superar sus desequilibrios
exteriores.
¿Entendeis ahora porque es tan importante?
Del recate del FMI pasariamos al megarescate
de Vaca Muerta.
Sin embargo amigos, esperad un momento, porque
las cosas no son tan sencillas.
Atentos.
(LA POLÍTICA, SIEMPRE LA POLÍTICA)
Una pregunta, ¿Os acordáis del descubrimiento
de Repsol en 2011 que hemos comentado antes?
Pues, amigos, esa gran noticia fue sin embargo
el inicio de muchos, muchísimos problemas.
(Con tanto dinero de por medio…. La entonces
presidenta de Argentina, Cristina Fernández
de Kirchner tomó una polémica decisión:
nacionalizar de forma forzosa la empresa YPF,
la mayor petrolera argentina que en aquel
momento formaba parte del grupo Repsol.
De golpe y porrazo el gobierno argentino tomó
el mando… Y las cosas se pararon.
Tras la nacionalización no sólo comenzó
un largo proceso judicial que le ha terminado
costando al país muchísimo dinero, sino
que la inversión internacional se frenó
en seco.)
Y, amigos, el sector del petróleo es un sector
que requiere de inversiones gigantes de miles
y miles y miles de millones de dólares.
Al final el proyecto prácticamente parado.
Sin embargo en 2015 con la llegada al poder
de Mauricio Macri, el proyecto volvió a cobrar
vida y comenzó una enorme lluvia de millones
para poder explotar este gran tesoro.
Pero aún hace falta mucho, muchísimo más.
¿Permitirán los políticos argentinos que
Vaca Muerta se desarrolle? ¿Logrará Argentina
sacar provecho de Vaca Muerta?
Dejadnos vuestras opiniones en los comentarios.
Y ya sabéis no olvidéis suscribiros a VisualPolitik
y si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante,
dadle a like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.